okay
sent in by a listener i got his video
right here
aunt rhonda dude this kid wants to fight
shop next
he's a cop you gotta need a face kid
looks like yeah dude he's from
kazakhstan
the morning king is tin crew i'm josh
from south carolina i submitted my aunt
ronnie from virginia
she's a caring grandmother during the
weekdays and a cougar on the prowl on
the weekend
that's my vibe daddy dude and selling
cars but now she's sling some white
squares
and i ain't talking about cocaine theo
hey man talking about mail
uh her favorite hobbies include young
men
and uh gang gang buzz bun
she's like young yeah yeah dude well
that's it thank you
slang in the mail dude i freaking
respect that yeah dude that's [ __ ]
cool you're taking a fun time
visiting that box homie nobody ever
[ __ ] the male lady
or the male guy even the male mailmen do
you think the mailmen get more
who gets more [ __ ] the mailman or the
milkman well look let's be honest
there's no milkman anymore but i'm
saying historically and i'm gonna
i'm gonna i mean i just said this the
other day but let's
the male basically the male these days
is just handing your the mail to a black
eye and hoping he takes it where
you think he's gonna take it yeah let's
be honest for usps
it's basically just giving the mail to a
black guy and hoping he's not racist
enough
that he'll deliver it to where i think
it needs to
[Laughter]
they scared the [ __ ] out of my mom's dog
yeah dude one thing that is scary though
about the media they make it they make a
lot of more white people i think are
more scared than ever sure i feel like
there's a lot more fear than there has
been i felt like
i feel like um which has been because i
used to feel like
less scared against uh different
ethnicities and now i feel more scared
against different
ethnicities sometimes not like in an
individual moment but like this is
general invisible fear you know
yeah so i think that's the kind of stuff
that the media social media has created
that
yeah because i don't feel that at all
i'm around [ __ ] minorities all the
time i don't feel that at all
like a mexican you look like a big
mexican dude though yeah i get it
and you're also a former ufc fighter so
people are fearful around you yeah
that's true dude you're
physical you've always said you're small
and feel looks like he's transitioning
but you should be scared i'm a former
used to work at a pizza place
okay we're the first to die when it
comes to racial matters
100 yeah the pizza delivery guy
gets killed immediately and dude theo
looks like an
old school white like he looks like a
historic one he does not
he looks like problems dude you look
like the most white
yeah dude but i also look nazi white and
people are still scared of the nazis
dude but you even will carry a cardboard
cut out of your puerto rican daughter to
get clowns oh dude
man every time i hit the stage i think
of a different more puerto rican name
for my daughter
her name's delilah the widest name i go
julissa mariah
yeah because yeah dude that's to get out
of jail
a diverse kid dude that's why i have a
puerto rican daughter man it's for my
career
this is my daughter daddy yankee
my daughter here georgia o'keefe
is she mexican or not oh george oakley
yes
is she i don't know oh no i'm thinking
of uh frida kahlo
oh the unibrow yeah the unibrow girl
from the museum
[Music]
is